[Applause]
[Music]
one of the most surprising things about
Japan and there are many surprising
things is quite how safe it is see Japan
is one of the few countries in the world
where you can leave an iPhone 10 in a
coffee shop and the only thing you've
got to worry about is dropping by the
next date and get it because the viewer
it is almost certain that you're
recently released brand new iPhone 10
will be there waiting for you at the
next day I'm not even exaggerating here
also Japan is a beautiful country with
amazing sights where everything seems to
be exactly where it should be
[Music]
but as you know this is not a Travel
Channel and this video is indeed not
sponsored by Japan's Ministry of Tourism
so let us get right to the point er
[Music]
recently we will find out that Emperor
hito has decided to abdicate the Emperor
of Japan will step down on April 30th
2019 the first abdication by a Japanese
monarch in two centuries well see this
emperor came to the throne almost 30
years ago in 1989 just when the great
Japanese crisis began so know in Japan
the emperor has no power so Akihito
wasn't responsible but don't say that
can't be just coincidence and bad luck
we can practically say that it was after
Iquitos arrival that thirty years of
stagnation began and in this video we're
gonna see what happens what caused this
great crisis and why the German economic
model has managed to defeat the Japanese
model but first of u're let's have a
small history lesson
[Music]
miracles exist
[Applause]
van and Germany are two very interesting
countries with a lot in common and also
many differences after the Second World
War both countries were literally in
ruins they had lost not only their
infrastructure but also an entire
generation however despite this between
the 1950s in the 1970s both countries
experienced such a powerful take off
that in those two decades they not only
managed to recover but become two of the
largest economies in the world as well
as two of the richest countries in fact
even there might seem incredible today
for years it was speculated that Japan
could surpass even the United States as
the world's largest economy and oh how
things have changed the fact is that
between 1955 and 1973 Japan grew at an
average rate of 9% a year and between
1973 and 1990 above 4% these are really
truly incredible rates and Germany
didn't stay behind is at an average
growth rate of 7% for almost 30 years
both countries were at full throttle
their factories worked tirelessly there
was no unemployment and both Germans and
the Japanese saved and invested their
money all over the world suddenly
Japanese and German companies became
famous worldwide
[Applause]
this was very important especially for
Japan a country that lives constantly
under nature's threat besides being a
very mountainous country Japan suffers
from all kinds of natural disasters
earthquakes cyclones tsunamis etc etc
etc by the way in a future visual
politic video hit subscribe we're going
to tell you all about how these two
economic miracles took place
[Music]
while the fact is that in 1989 this
entire economic takeoff stopped it came
to an end and gave way to what is known
as the great Japanese stagnation forget
Greece Japan is the world's real
economic time bomb
Christopher Matthews an ex US reporter
I'm pretty convinced this isn't news to
you as it isn't strange to hear people
talk about Japan along with the word
crisis the other evidence I can record
Japan has been the country of eternal
crisis the country that has one good
year for every three bad ones in fact
nowadays we can easily declare Germany
the winner in the growth race that both
countries maintained for decades
see today Germany which has also gone
through some bad times in recent decades
is richer as healthier public accounts
is more competitive internationally and
has higher wages she has an idea of
japan's situation i think we can use two
very revealing facts first in japan real
wages which take into account inflation
are lower today than salaries back in
1990 which was 30 years ago and seconds
the Japanese government's public debt is
the highest in the world 250 percent of
GDP yes we didn't screw that up that is
really the debt figure
[Music]
so Divya you might have me wondering
about what the hell happens what made
the German model so much better than the
Japanese well obviously there are lots
of reasons but we believe that three of
them are by far the most important so
we're going to take a look at them right
now
[Music]
a problematic model first we can say
that there was a big difference between
Japan and Germany's developments the
country of the Rising Sun opted to
protect large industrial conglomerates
the carrot soup the carrots ooh are so
to speak Holdings that do practically
everything that is they have companies
for all kinds of things cars planes
tires even toothpaste everything is
manufactured by the same holding company
whose companies support each other buy
and sell products between themselves and
even have their own banks to finance
themselves so what's the problem with
this well these large conglomerates
tended to be very bureaucratic and not
very flexible
so decision-making was a very difficult
and slow process but the Japanese
government decided to compensate them
for all of these disadvantages and
didn't hesitate to give the key retsu
all kinds of advantages and privileges
for example Japan's central bank
financed them generously at abnormally
low rates through specific programs
however the results they were not good
see these large groups became very
influential in the country's politics
they also had many problems because of
course when one of these conglomerates
companies did badly it was extremely
easy for them to infect the rest they
were also in a lot of debt and they even
limited competition I mean how can one
compete with such groups if they are
also protected by the government and
have all kinds of privileges it's a
pretty hard thing to ask on the other
hand in Germany the political
commitments was completely different and
focused on creating a very competitive
market with small and medium sized
companies
but are there large industrial groups in
Germany well of course there are and
that's a good thing as long as they
don't depend on the government or
receive privileges that impede
competition so while Germany's companies
thrived Japan's large conglomerates have
had many problems and most have
disappeared or broken down at some point
but that's not all
[Music]
the discount policy
for years Japanese politicians thought
that in order to export more devaluing
for currency from time to time was not a
bad thing however in 1985 the real
problems began see as a result of all
these currency wars the United States
gained a fairly large external deficit
and because Washington politicians of
the time as they do now didn't like it
they forced the so-called plaza record
and agreements between the United States
Japan Germany France and the United
Kingdom to depreciate the dollar to
decrease the trade deficit as you can
imagine this was a huge blow to the
Japanese industry who was used to
competing with a little bit of help and
then the government sank its interest
rates and began boosting credit like
there was no tomorrow
[Music]
and the result of this well that was a
huge debt spiral banks distributing
money like crazy and a massive bubble in
the real estate and financial markets
and you know happened next well in 1990
this entire house of cards began to
collapse in Germany however as we also
saw here at visual politic the
government's opted to maintain a strong
mark their currency at the time which on
one hand forced companies to compete in
productivity and innovation but on the
other allowed them to buy foreign
technology and machines and a better
terms
but dear viewer there is still a third
and determinant difference
locked within themselves
Japan is the most elderly country in the
world's just over 25% of its population
that is everyone in for Japanese people
are over 65 and for every hour that
passes the country's population drops by
50 people because the Japanese
government expects the country's
population to fall below 100 million
people by the year 2050 and of course
the more elderly citizens there are the
less young people there are and the
lower the population this has clear
consequences for one more public
spending on pensions and health care and
for another less labor
[Music]
many other countries have this problem
but Japan's case is by far the most
serious and this isn't by chance at all
[Music]
Japanese companies have compensated for
all of the problems caused by the bad
policies that we talked about in this
video they force their employees to work
longer hours than in other developed
countries which obviously leaves very
little time to think about starting a
family and what's more some countries
like Germany have favored the arrival of
immigrants who tend to have higher
population growth rates Japan has closed
its doors in fact when international
organizations tell Japan they have to
open their borders to immigration to
face the aging problem the Japanese
government's has even said this Japan's
Finance Minister tells elderly they
should hurry up and die to help reduce
country's rising welfare bill so these
are the fundamental causes that have led
Japan to live in continuous crisis and
the causes that have made the German
model clearly better than the Japanese
one so now over to you do you think that
Japan will be able to overcome this
period of stagnation and seemingly
permanent crisis well leave your answer
in the comments below as well as in this
survey and I also really hope you
enjoyed this video please do hit that
like button if you did and don't forget
to subscribe to our channel for brand
new videos every Monday and Thursday
also do not forget to check out our
friends at the reconsider Media podcast
they provided the vocals in this episode
but were not mine and as always thank
you for watching
[Music]